history up close and personal costumes
from the time period and a replica of
the original vehicle Archduke Franz
Ferdinand was riding in when he was
assassinated the spark that ignited a
world war a century later the
commemoration attracted a number of
peace activists Sevilla some nice if we
observed a second of silence for each of
the 18 million innocent people who were
killed we'd have to stay quiet for two
years we should take that a message that
you know killing somebody was resulting
in a big war where millions of millions
died so killing is no solution we should
talk together we should work together we
should live together in peace that we
can learn from that time but the lessons
of history are difficult to learn the
anniversary has touched upon the ever
sensitive and deeply felt differences
between ethnic Serbs and other Bosnians
many Serbs ignored the official
commemorations and chose instead to
celebrate Gavrilo Princip the teenager
who assassinated the Archduke they see
him as a hero who fought for freedom
from the occupiers from Vienna the city
hall also has a story rooted in local
conflict Serb forces destroyed it in
1992 along with the National Library it
housed newly renovated it's seen as a
symbol of hope